Now coming to your question. If someone
robs you now that you started believing
in God and now you know that God is more
powerful than you, wouldn't you want
justice? Because before a person
believes in God, he thinks he's top of
the world. He thinks he's God. He
doesn't believe in God. So he thinks
he's number one. Now when he starts
believing in God, he realize God is all
powerful. God is not just. How will God
give justice in this world? God doesn't
give full justice in this world. May get
may not get. Even if you good do good
deeds, you may get reward here. You may
get reward in barak. But the main reward
is aka. Therefore, we say if something
goes wrong, alhamdulillah, we'll get the
reward in Akar. That's what we Muslim
believe. IF SOMEONE ROBS ME, NO PROBLEM.
I will get the reward in a because I yet
believe in God. Now I'm asking you the
question that if you're a logical human
being, if you believe punishment only in
this world, hypothetically if you catch
Hitler, Hitler incinerated 6 million
Jews. Correct? Now hypothetically if the
police catches Hitler, what punishment
can you give in this world? Tell me. If
you catch Hitler who has incinerated 6
million Jews, what punishment can you
give him? Burn him once. Correct. What
about the remaining 5,999,999?
Is it justice? Is it justice? No. So
some people who do such big crimes like
Hitler and mafia, even if you catch him,
even if you torture him, even if you
burn him, maximum one death. Allah says
in the Quran in surah Isisa chapter 4
verse 56 as to those who reject our
signs we shall cast them in the hellfire
and as often as the skins are roasted we
will give them fresh skin so that we
shall feel the pain. Today science tells
us that the pain receptors are in the
skin. Once the pain receptor gets burnt
the human being does not feel pain. So
in this world if you are burned only
once after that no pain you die. Allah
says in the next life in janams
as to the unbelievers who don't believe
in Allah we shall cast them into the
hellfire and as often as the skins are
roasted Allah will give them fresh skin
so that they shall feel the pain. So in
this life maximum once in hereafter if
Allah wants to burn HITLER 6 MILLION
TIMES he can do it yes or no he can do
it 12 million times also yes or no so
Allah knows the justice so believing in
one god IS IMPORTANT BUT WITHOUT a
it's not complete therefore one of the
pillars of imman is believing in akar
believing in Allah believing in the
books
Believing in the angels, believing in
the messengers, believing in a believing
in destiny. Six pillars of Iman. So
believing in a one of the pillars of Im
only believing is God is not sufficient.
Correct? So even if you believe in God,
unless you don't believe in a you cannot
prove logically robbing is bad, cheating
is bad, raping is bad. You rape a girl,
you enjoy what is wrong. Very good.
Enjoy.
Only way you can prove is wrong is by
believing in a so besides believing in
Allah, believing in a is very important.
WITHOUT THAT YOU CANNOT PROVE robbing is
bad, cheating is bad, raping is bad. You
cannot. So Islam is a complete way of
life. It's a complete belief. Not only
believing in Allah, believing in the
messenger, believing in a believing in
the angels, believing in the books,
believing in destiny.